Black cats and goblins
and broomsticks and ghosts.
Covens of witches with all of their hosts.
You may think they scare me,
you're probably right.
Black cats and goblins
on Halloween night.
Trick or treat!
My parents won't be home until 10:00.
- Are you sure?
- Uh-huh.
We are alone, aren't we?
Michael's around some place.
Take off that thing.
- Let's go upstairs.
- Okay.
Your hands are cold.
Look, Judith,
it's really late. I gotta go.
Will you call me tomorrow?
- Yeah, sure.
- Promise?
Yeah.
Michael?
Oh, God!
Ever done anything like this before?
- Only minimum security.
- I see.
The driveway's
a few hundred yards up on your right.
The only thing that ever bothers me
is their gibberish,
when they start raving on and on.
You don't have anything to worry about.
He hasn't spoken a word in 15 years.
Are there any special instructions?
Just try to understand
what we're dealing with here.
Don't underestimate it.
Don't you think we could refer
to it as him?
If you say so.
Your compassion's
overwhelming, doctor.
What do I give him when we take him
in front of the judge?
Thorazine.
- He'll barely be able to sit up.
- That's the idea.
- You're serious about it, aren't you?
- Yeah.
You mean you actually never want him
to get out?
Never, never... Never.
Then why are we taking him up
to Hardin County if we just gonna...?
Because that is the law.
Here we are.
Since when did they let them
wander around?
Pull up to the main gate.
- Shouldn't we put...
- Go on, move!
Stop here.
Shouldn't we go on up
to the hospital ins...
Wait.
- Are you all right? You all right?
- Yes, I'm okay.
He's gone. He's gone from here!
The evil is gone!
All right, I got it.
Don't forget to drop off the key off
at the Myers' place.
I won't.
They're coming by to look
at the house at 10:30.
- Be sure you leave it under the mat.
- Promise!
Laurie!
Hi, Tommy.
- Coming over tonight?
- Same time, same place.
- Can we make jack-o'-lanterns?
- Sure.
- Can we watch the monster movies?
Will you read to me?
Can we make popcorn?
Sure, sure, sure.
You better hurry up.
How come you're walking
to school this way?
- My dad asked me to.
- Why?
- I have to drop off a key.
- Because he's gonna sell a house.
- Why?
- Because that's his job.
- Where?
- The Myers' house.
- The Myers' house?
- You're not supposed to go up there.
- Yes, I am.
- Uh-uh. That's a spook house.
- Just watch.
Lonnie Elamb said never to go up there.
Lonnie Elamb said that's a haunted house.
He said awful stuff
happened there once.
Lonnie Elamb probably won't get out
of the sixth grade.
I gotta go. I'll see you tonight.
- Bye.
I wish I had you all alone.
Just the two of us.
I would hold you close to me.
So close to me.
Just the two of us.
- I'm not responsible, Sam.
- Oh, no.
- I told them how dangerous he was...
- You could have had two roadblocks
and an all-points bulletin,
it wouldn't stop a 5-year-old.
Well, he was your patient, doctor.
If precautions weren't strong enough,
you should have told somebody.
- I told everybody! Nobody listened.
- There's nothing else I can do.
You could get back there
and get back on the telephone,
tell them exactly who walked
out of here last night,
- and tell them exactly where he's going.
- Probably going.
I'm wasting my time.
Sam, Haddonfield is 150 miles
away from here.
Now, for God's sakes,
he can't drive a car.
He was doing very well last night.
Maybe someone around here
gave him lessons.
Dr. Chance, please report to Ward C.
Dr. Chance, Ward C, please.
And the book ends.
But what Samuels is really talking
about here is fate.
You see, fate caught up
with several lives here.
No matter what course of action
Collins took,
he was destined to his own fate,
his own day of reckoning with himself.
The idea is that destiny
is a very real, concrete thing
that every person has to deal with.
How does Samuels' view of fate
differ from that of Costain's?
Laurie?
- Ma'am?
- Answer the question.
Oh, um, Costain wrote that fate
was somehow related only to religion,
whereas Samuels felt that, well,
fate was like a natural element,
like earth, air, fire and water.
That's right.
Samuels definitely personified fate.
In Samuels' writing,
fate is immovable, like a mountain.
It stands where man passes away.
Fate never changes.
- Yeah.
- Stupid pumpkin.
- Yeah, how's the little witches?
- Yeah, stupid pumpkin.
Leave me alone.
He's gonna get you.
He's gonna get you,
he's gonna get you...
The boogeyman is coming.
- Leave me alone!
- He doesn't believe us.
Don't you know what happens
on Halloween?
Yeah, we get candy.
The boogeyman, ooh, the boogeyman.
The boogeyman,
the boogeyman, the boogeyman...
He's on his way.
You've gotta believe me, officer.
He is coming to Haddonfield.
Because I know him.
I'm his doctor.
You must be ready for him.
If you don't, it's your funeral.
We're from Haddonfield,
couldn't be prouder.
Can't hear us now,
we'll yell a little louder.
We're from Haddonfield,
couldn't be prouder...
Oh, look at you!
Look all the books you have.
You need a shopping cart to get home.
- Hey, Haddonfield!
- Yeah, not funny.
You know, it's totally insane.
We have three new cheers
to learn in the morning,
the game is in the afternoon,
I have to get my hair done at 5:00,
and the dance is at 8:00.
I'll be totally wiped out!
I don't think you have enough
to do tomorrow.
Totally.
As usual, I have nothing to do.
It's your own fault
and I don't feel a bit sorry for you.
Hey, Lynda, Laurie!
Why didn't you wait for me?
We did. Fifteen minutes,
you totally never showed.
That's not true. Here I am.
What's wrong, Annie?
You're not smiling.
I'm never smiling again.
Paul dragged me
into the boys' locker room to tell me...
Exploring uncharted territory?
- It's been totally charted.
- We just talked.
- Sure, sure.
- Sure. Mm-hmm.
Old jerk-o got caught throwing eggs
and soaping windows.
His parents grounded him.
He can't come over tonight.
I thought
you were babysitting tonight.
Only reason she babysits
is to have a place...
- Shit.
- I have a place for that.
I forgot my chemistry book.
So who cares? I always forget
my chemistry book.
And my math book, and my English book,
and my, let's see, my French book and...
Oh, who needs books anyway? I don't need
books, I always forget all of my books.
I mean, it doesn't really matter if you
have your books or not.
Hey, isn't that Devon Graham?
I don't think so.
I think he's cute.
Hey, jerk!
Speed kills!
God, can't you take a joke?
You know, Annie, someday, you're going
to get us all into deep trouble.
Totally.
I hate a guy with a car
and no sense of humor.
Well, are we still on for tonight?
I wouldn't wanna get you
in deep trouble, Lynda.
Oh, come on, Annie! Bob and I
have been planning on it all week.
All right. The Wallaces leave at 7:00.
I'm babysitting the Doyles.
It's only three houses down.
We can keep each other company.
Oh, terrific. I've got three choices.
Watch the kid sleep, listen to Lynda
screw around, or talk to you.
I am so mad.
Why don't you buy your own then?
You bummed 20 off me, girl.
- What time tonight?
- I don't know yet.
I have to get out of taking
my little brother trick-or-treating.
- Saving the treats for Bob?
- Funny. See you.
- Bye.
- Annie, look.
- Look where?
Behind the bush.
I don't see anything.
The guy who drove by so fast,
the one you yelled at?
Oh, subtle, isn't he?
Hey, creep.
Laurie, dear, he wants to talk to you.
He wants to take you out tonight.
He was standing right there.
Poor Laurie!
You scared another one away.
It's tragic. You never go out.
You must have a small fortune stashed
from babysitting so much.
Guys think I'm too smart.
I don't, I think you're whacko.
Now you're seeing men behind bushes.
Well, home sweet home.
See you later.
- Bye.
- Excuse me, Laurie.
- Oh, Mr. Brackett!
I'm sorry, Mr. Brackett.
- Oh, I didn't mean to startle you.
- Oh, it's all right.
You know, it's Halloween.
I guess everyone's entitled
to one good scare, huh?
Yes, sir. Nice seeing you, sir.
Oh, no.
No.
- Trick or treat.
Well, kiddo,
I thought you outgrew superstition.
Hello.
Hello?
Who is this?
- Hello?
- Why'd you hang up on me?
- Annie? Was that you?
- Of course.
Why didn't you say anything?
You scared me to death.
I had my mouth full.
Couldn't you hear me?
Thought it was an obscene phone call.
Now you hear obscene chewing.
You're losing it, Laurie.
- I already lost it.
- I doubt that.
Listen, my mother is letting me
use her car. I'll pick you up, 6:30.
- Okay, bye.
- Bye.
Just calm down.
This is ridiculous.
- Hurry up.
- Hi.
We just have time.
Yeah, Judith Myers. Myers...
"Row 18, plot 20."
Yeah, you know, you know, every town
has something like this happen.
I remember over in Russellville,
old Charlie Bowles, about 15 years ago.
One night, he finished dinner,
and excused himself from the table.
And he went out to the garage.
He got himself a hacksaw.
And then he went back into the house,
and he kissed his wife
and his two children goodbye,
and then he proceeded...
- Where are we?
- Huh?
Oh, it's right over here.
Yeah, Myers, Judith Myers.
I remember her.
Couldn't believe it.
Such a young boy.
What's the matter, are you lost?
Why do they do it? Goddamn kids!
They'll do anything for Halloween.
- Whose grave is it?
- Oh, I don't know. Uh...
Eighteen, 19...
Judith Myers.
He came home.
- You still spooked?
- I wasn't spooked.
- Lies.
- I wasn't!
I saw somebody standing
in Mr. Riddle's backyard.
- Probably Mr. Riddle.
- He was watching me.
Mr. Riddle was watching you?
Laurie, Mr. Riddle is 87!
- He can still watch.
- That's probably all he can do.
- What's the pumpkin for?
- I brought it for Tommy.
I figured carving a jack-o'-lantern
would keep him occupied.
I always said
you'd make a fabulous Girl Scout.
Thanks.
And for that matter, I might as well
be a Girl Scout myself tonight.
I plan on making popcorn
and watching Dr. Dementia.
Six straight hours of horror movies.
Little Lindsey Wallace
won't know what hit her.
My dad! Get rid of this.
Laurie, stop coughing.
- What's the matter with you?
- Jesus!
Just be natural. There he is.
Just be natural, Laurie.
Hi, Annie, Laurie.
- Hi.
- Hi, Dad, what happened?
- What?
- What happened?
Oh, uh, somebody broke
into the hardware store. Probably kids.
You blame everything on kids.
Well, all they took
was some Halloween masks,
a rope, and a couple of knives.
Now, who do you think it was?
It's hard growing up
with a cynical father.
- Aren't you gonna be late?
- Huh?
I said aren't you gonna be late?!
He shouts too.
Bye, girls.
- Bye, Dad.
- Bye.
Sheriff?
Pardon me, I'm, uh, Loomis.
Dr. Sam Loomis.
Uh, Lee Brackett.
I'd like to have a word
with you if I could.
- Maybe a few minutes. I gotta take care...
- It's important.
- Ten minutes.
- I'll be here.
What's the matter with you?
I think he knew.
I'm sure he could smell it.
- No, he didn't.
- He did. See the look on his face?
He always looks like that.
What are you gonna wear
to the dance tomorrow?
I didn't know you thought
about things like that, Laurie.
- You know, you could ask somebody.
- Oh, I couldn't.
Sure you could. All you have to do
is go up to somebody and say:
"You wanna go to the dance?"
You could do that. I couldn't.
Well, you could ask Dick Baxter.
He'd go out with you.
I'd rather go out with Ben Tramer.
Ben Tramer? I knew it!
So you do think about
things like that, huh, Laurie?
- Shut up.
- He's cute.
- Ben Tramer.
- Shh.
Okay.
Trick or treat, trick or treat.
Give me something good to eat.
Trick or treat, trick or treat,
give me something good to eat...
- Hi.
- Hi, Annie. Come on in.
Uh, be in bed by 9:00, Lindsey, okay?
- Have a good night, dear.
- Be a good girl.
- Bye-bye.
- See you.
- Take care.
- Okay.
- Does anybody live here?
- No, not since 1963, when it happened.
Every kid in Haddonfield thinks
this place is haunted.
They may be right.
- Look.
- What?
What is that?
It's a dog.
Still warm.
He got hungry.
- Come on. It could've been a skunk.
- Could have.
- A man wouldn't do that.
- This isn't a man.
It happened in here.
She was sitting right here.
He could have seen her
through this window.
Standing on the lawn,
he could have seen inside.
Huh, you must think me
a very sinister doctor.
Oh, um, I do have a permit.
Seems to me you're just plain scared.
Yes. Yeah, I am, uh...
I met him 15 years ago.
I was told there was nothing left.
No reason, no, uh, conscience,
no understanding in even the most
rudimentary sense of life or death,
of good or evil,
of right or wrong.
I met this 6-year-old child
with this blank, pale,
emotionless face,
and the blackest eyes.
The devil's eyes.
I spent eight years trying to reach him.
And then another seven trying
to keep him locked up,
because I realized that what was living
behind that boy's eyes
was purely and simply evil.
What do we do?
He's been here once tonight.
I think he'll come back.
I'm gonna wait for him.
I still think I should notify
the radio and television...
No. If you do that, they'll see him
on every street corner,
look for him in every house.
Just tell your men to keep
their mouths shut and their eyes open.
I'll check back in an hour.
"'How now, ' cried Arthur.
'Let no one pass this way
without a fight.'
'Is that so?, ' said the knight,
in a bold and haughty manner."
- I don't like that story.
- I thought King Arthur was your favorite.
Not anymore.
- Why do you keep them under there?
- Mom doesn't like me to have them.
"Laser Man."
"Neutron Man." I can understand why.
"Tarantula Man."
Laurie, what's the boogeyman?
Doyle residence.
- It's me.
- Hi, Annie, what are you doing?
Making popcorn.
Having fun?
Never mind, I'm sure you are.
I have big, big news for you.
Oops. Hold on a minute.
Hi, Lester.
I'm about to be ripped apart
by the family dog.
Lindsey, get this dog out
of the kitchen right now.
I hate that dog. I'm the only person
in the world he doesn't like.
So, what is this big, big news?
What would you say if I told you
that you were going to the homecoming
dance tomorrow night?
I'd probably say
you have the wrong number.
Well... I just talked with Ben Tramer,
and he got real excited when I told him
how attracted you were to him.
Oh, Annie! Oh, you didn't.
Please tell me you didn't.
How could you do that?
I mean, how can you just call him...
What do you mean it was easy?
I can't believe this.
I can't tell you anything.
Every time I tell you something,
everyone else knows about it.
No, I'm not mad.
Please tell me you didn't.
Oh, you didn't.
- Laurie.
- Oh, I'm so embarrassed.
- The boogeyman is outside.
- I couldn't even face him.
- Laurie, he's out there.
- Hold on.
Laurie, the boogeyman
is outside. Look.
Tommy, there's nobody outside.
Go watch TV.
It's just Tommy.
Oh, please, tell me you didn't.
How could you do that?
Look, it's simple.
You like him, he likes you.
All you need is a little push.
Well, it won't hurt you to go out
with him, for God's sake!
Shit!
No, no, I just made a mess of myself.
I gotta call you back.
Oh, yuck!
Lindsey, I need a robe!
Little creep.
Lindsey, Lester's barking again
and getting on my nerves again.
Oh, never mind.
I guess he found a hot date.
- What about the jack-o'-lantern?
- After the movie.
- What about the rest of my comic books?
- After the jack-o'-lantern.
- And what about the boogeyman?
- There's no such thing.
Richie said
he was coming after me tonight.
Do you believe everything
Richie tells you?
No.
Tommy, Halloween night... it's
when people play tricks on each other.
It's all make-believe. I think Richie
was just trying to scare you.
I saw the boogeyman. I saw him outside.
There was nobody outside.
- There was.
- What did he look like?
The boogeyman.
We're not getting anywhere.
All right. The boogeyman can only
come out on Halloween night, right?
- Right.
- Well, I'm here tonight.
I'm not about to let
anything happen to you.
- Promise?
- Promise.
- Can we make the jack-o'-lantern now?
- Let's go.
Hmm, terrific.
Hello?
Who's there?
Paul, is this one of your cheap tricks?
Guess not.
No tricks for Annie tonight.
Come on.
Lindsey!
Lindsey, come out here!
Lindsey, I'm in the laundry room.
The door won't open.
Spread out, everybody. We're gonna try
to figure out the shape of this thing.
Holy cats.
- Hey.
- Yeah.
Almost a perfect...
- We finally got one.
- We found a flying saucer.
Oh, Lindsey,
get the phone! It's Paul!
Lindsey! Lindsey!
Please hold. I'm here.
Oh, excellent.
- Where do you figure it's from?
- I don't know.
Hello?
Hi, Lindsey, this is Paul.
Is Annie there?
- Yes, she is.
- Get her for me, will you?
- She's washing her clothes.
- Look, just tell her it's me, okay?
Okay.
Annie, Paul called!
- You locked yourself in.
- I know!
Pull my foot. I'm stuck.
Now, promise me
you won't tell anybody about this.
She got stuck in the window.
She'll be right here.
- Hello.
- Hi, Annie.
- Oh, hi, Paul.
- Stuck, huh?
All right, cut it out.
It can happen to anyone.
Sure, stuck in the window.
Yeah, but I've seen you stuck
in plenty of other positions.
My parents are gone.
Oh, that's fabulous.
When did they leave?
About a half-hour ago.
Oh, utterly fantastic.
- So why don't you just walk over?
- You come and pick me up.
Oh, I can't come now.
My clothes are in the wash.
- You won't need them.
- Oh, shut up, jerk.
God, I've got a shirt on.
That's all you ever think about.
I think that's all you ever think about.
That's no true.
I think about lots of things.
Now why don't we not stand here
talking about them
and get down to doing them?
Lock your doors,
bolt your windows
and turn off the lights.
Don't go away,
because here's a scene from...
I'm scared.
Then why are you sitting here
with all the lights off?
- I don't know.
- Well, come on, get your coat.
- We're going to pick up Paul.
- I don't want to.
Look, Lindsey,
I thought we understood each other.
I wanna stay here and watch this.
Okay.
Well, if I can fix it so you can watch TV
with Tommy Doyle, would you like that?
- Yeah.
- Well, come with me.
Come on, hurry up!
Hi, Tommy.
Hi, come on in.
We're making a jack-o'-lantern.
- You know, I wanna watch TV.
- How would you like that, kiddies?
- Good.
- Annie, I'm in here.
And now, the horrifying conclusion
to The Thing.
- All fancy.
- This has not been my night.
I spilled butter all over my clothes,
they're in the wash.
- I got stuck in the laundry room.
- Let me tell you something.
I'd like you to call Ben Tramer and tell
him that you were just fooling around.
- I can't.
- Yes, you can.
No, he went drinking with Mike Godfrey
and he won't be back till late.
You'll have to call him tomorrow.
Besides, I'm on my way to pick up Paul.
Wait a minute...
If you watch her, I'll consider
talking to Ben Tramer in the morning.
Deal.
- I thought Paul was grounded.
- He was.
Old jerk-o found a way to sneak out.
Listen, I'll call you
in an hour or so, okay?
Yeah.
- Bye.
The old Girl Scout
comes through again.
My Paul, I give you all...
No keys, but please, my Paul.
Oh, Paul, I can no longer stall.
Oh, Paul.
Dear Paul.
My Paul.
Attention, Captain to crew.
Stand by to reverse polarity.
Standard class-A security
will be maintained upon landing.
And until further notice, all hands
will wear sidearms. That is all.
- Artificial gravity off.
- Aft locked.
- Cut primary coils.
- Primary's cut, sir.
Lindsey.
- Lindsey.
- Where are you?
Hey, it's the boogeyman!
He's outside! The boogeyman's outside!
- Look, there's the boogeyman!
- What's wrong?
- I saw the boogeyman. He's at Lindsey's...
- Oh, Tommy, stop it.
- You're scaring Lindsey.
- He's outside! He's over there at...
Tommy, stop it!
Now, there's nobody out there.
There's no boogeyman,
and if you don't stop all this,
I'm gonna turn off the TV
and send you to bed.
- Nobody believes me.
- I believe you, Tommy.
- I'm not afraid.
- Bull.
- I'm not.
- Then go in.
- Chicken!
- Go ahead, Lonnie.
Go in!
Hey.
Hey, Lonnie.
Get your ass away from there.
Jesus.
- Are you all right?
- Yeah.
Nothing's going on
except kids playing pranks,
trick-or-treating,
parking, getting high.
I have the feeling
that you're way off on this.
You have the wrong feeling.
Well, you're not doing very much
to prove me wrong.
What more do you need?
Well, it's gonna take
more than fancy talk
to keep me up all night,
crawling around these bushes.
I watched him for 15 years,
sitting in a room, staring at a wall,
not seeing the wall,
looking past the wall,
looking at this night,
inhumanly patient.
Waiting for some secret silent alarm
to trigger him off.
Death has come
to your little town, sheriff.
You can either ignore it
or you can help me to stop it.
More fancy talk. Doctor,
do you know what Haddonfield is?
Families, children, all lined up in rows
up and down these streets.
You're telling me
they're lined up for a slaughterhouse.
They could be.
All right, I'll stay with you tonight,
just on the chance that you're right.
And if you are right,
damn you for letting him go.
Okay, so we're gonna...
First we go inside, right?
Then we'll just talk a little.
Then Annie will distract Lindsey,
that's when we go upstairs,
to the first bedroom on the left.
- You got it?
- Okay, first I rip your clothes off.
No, don't rip my blouse.
It's expensive, idiot.
Then you rip my clothes off.
Then we rip Lindsey's clothes off.
- Yeah, I think I got it.
- Totally.
No, no!
Bob, put me down!
Put me down! This is totally silly!
Put me down!
- Hey, it's totally dark.
- Yeah.
Hey, Annie!
- Annie, we're here!
- I wonder where they went.
Oh, Annie probably took Lindsey out
for something.
- Hey, let's look for a note.
- Let's don't.
- He's gonna get you.
- No, he's not.
Hey, nobody's getting anybody.
Stop scaring each other.
Everybody's having a good time tonight.
- All right, you guys, what's next?
- Let's make more popcorn.
No, we've had enough.
Why don't we watch the rest of the movie?
- Yeah.
Doyle house.
Hi, Laurie. What's up?
Uh, I'm just sitting down
for the first time tonight.
Hey, is Annie around?
No. I thought she'd be home by now.
She went to pick up Paul.
Well, she's totally not here.
She probably stopped off some place.
Have her call me when she gets home.
I have Lindsey here and I wanna know
what time to put her to bed.
- Okay. Later.
- Have a good time.
We definitely will.
Bye.
- Lindsey is gone for the night.
- Hey, now that's wonderful!
Oh, shit. Not again.
I can't help it. The phone keeps ringing.
- Oh, and I can't keep you interested?
- Just answer the damn phone.
Well, I can't. What if it's the Wallaces?
We'd get Annie in trouble, you know.
Just take it off the hook.
Oh, fantastic.
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- Want a beer?
- Is that all you can say?
- Yeah.
- Go get me a beer.
- I thought you were gonna get me one.
Yeah?
I'll be right back.
Don't get dressed.
Annie?
Paul?
Lynda, you asshole!
Okay, Lynda. Come on out.
Well, did you get my beer?
Cute, Bob. Real cute.
See anything you like?
What's the matter?
Can't I get your ghost, Bob?
All right, all right.
Come on, where's my beer?
Well, can't you answer me?
Okay, don't answer me.
Boy, are you weird.
Well, I'm gonna call Laurie.
I wanna know where Paul and Annie are.
This is going nowhere.
Finally.
Hello?
All right, Annie.
First, I get your famous chewing,
now I get your famous squealing?
Annie, are you all right?
Are you fooling around again?
I'll kill you if this is a joke.
Annie?
Sleep tight, kids.
Bob?
Lynda?
Annie?
Bob?
All right, Annie.
All right, meatheads. Joke's over.
Come on, Annie. It's enough.
This most definitely stopped
being funny. Now, cut it out!
You'll be sorry.
Oh, God!
Oh. No.
Help.
No.
Help! Somebody help me, please!
Somebody help!
Oh, God, help me!
Please! Please help me!
Help!
Oh, God, help me, please!
Hello! Hello!
Hello, help me!
Can you please help me?! Please!
Can't you hear me?
Oh, God!
Help me, please!
The keys! Oh, the keys!
Tommy! Tommy, it's me!
Tommy!
- Who is it?
- Tommy, open up, it's me!
Yeah, okay.
Tommy, please!
Tommy, hurry up!
Tommy! Hurry up!
Tommy, please!
- Tommy, get upstairs.
- What is it?
Get upstairs, get Lindsey,
lock the bedroom door.
- I'm scared!
- Do as I say!
- The boogeyman...
- Hurry!
Oh, no.
Please stop.
Please.
Where were you?
I went to the Myers' house...
I found the car. He's here.
- Where?
- He's three blocks down.
You go around the back of the houses.
I'll watch the front.
- Go on!
- All right.
Tommy? Lindsey?
Babies.
- We're gonna take a little walk.
- Was it the boogeyman?
- I'm scared.
- There's nothing to be scared of.
Are you sure? How?
- I killed him.
- You can't kill the boogeyman.
Get in there, come on, Tommy!
Now lock the door!
Tommy, unlock the door.
Come here.
Now, just listen to me.
I want you to go down the stairs
and out the front door.
I want you to go down the street
to the Mackenzies' house.
I want you to tell them to call the police
and tell them to send them over here.
- Laurie...
- Now, do you understand me?
- Yes.
- Go, do as I say.
Come on! Get help!
Come on. Come on!
It was the boogeyman.
As a matter of fact, it was.